way cooler than a tanning bed
it's basically the power of a small star
hi i'm noah's kindergarten here in
newport beach my new home
today i'm going to hit a few of my
favorite businesses with a little help
from my wells fargo active cash visa
card
today we're kicking it off at natural
healing center we're gonna do their
superhuman protocol i do this about two
or three times a week this is really
important to me because i take a really
holistic approach on recovery go ahead
and lay down noel
we'll set you up that's the best part
right here and meditate
[Music]
pretty zen
i just use this as a
a nice opportunity to do some
mindfulness practices
this is really testing my ability to
stay mindful with all you guys around me
nap time's over that's right
second stage of the superhuman protocol
is oxygen therapy with exercise
get that oxygen to penetrate deeper into
the tissues
you're good that's a wrap mister
probably my favorite modality of the
superhuman protocol is the novothor it's
basically the power of a small star
really great for skin health collagen
production and it's just a euphoric
feeling when you're in there it was just
a happy coincidence that it happens to
have four in the name so my version of a
spa day and then that'll conclude the
superhuman protocol and then we're on to
the next spot thank you you're welcome
have a good one love that noah
feeling like a superhuman our next stop
is maxine in lido marina village howdy
phillip hey noah welcome
i came to pick up my cowboy hat that i
ordered last week you got it it's
unfortunate to cover up this beautiful
hair but
you gotta do what you gotta do
you look good you feel good you might
just play good
my favorite style of hat is a cowboy hat
or actually maybe a baseball hat but
secondly that would definitely be a
cowboy hat with just me being from texas
my father being a horse trainer
all right here we go all right
looks incredible
black western with a black leather band
i think it turned out great i think it's
uh my new everyday hat i'll ring you up
across the way all right
all right have a good one you too
i think wearing a cowboy hat it's the
ultimate power statement when it comes
to accessorizing your ensemble now i'm
going to go grab a coffee and read a
book down by the water
spot for you
i'll do a double espresso silver
especially if you like some food as well
today diy branzino fish tacos fantastic
choice it's my favorite
i don't think it's you're supposed to
wear cowboy hats at the table anyways i
think you're supposed to take them off
last year i started noah's book club to
promote that that reading and being
smart is cool it's another great way to
connect with fans in a positive way now
i'm going to pound this espresso
i'm going to be seeing noises after this
all right we've got the food here for
you all right white fish tacos
incredible
wow that was so much fun i had a great
time shopping and hanging out down here
and i love that i earned unlimited two
percent cash rewards on my purchases
using my wells fargo active cash visa
card
see you next time